welcome to this week's episode of Theory
Thursdays how's it going everybody i'm
warren and we have some really awesome
theories this week before we get started
with this week's theories
congratulations to Chris for being last
week's winner with theory number one
Congrats Chris you're now eligible to
win the monthly prize at the end of the
month if you would like to submit a
theory of your own for a chance to end
up in an episode of Theory Thursdays you
can find the email in the description
down below
alright let's dive right into some
theories our first theory this week
comes from Jai cousin from Australia and
he thinks that Harley keiner is actually
an incarnation of Nova Jai says that an
Iron Man 3 Harley lives with his mom and
little sister after his dad went missing
just like Sam Alexander and what if
between the events of Iron Man 3 -
in-game Harley has been using Iron Man's
technology that he left him to track
down his father and he finds the Nova
helmet and could have been in space
training for years maybe he was even on
Xandar when Thanos attacked making it a
personal vendetta for him and he was
about 15 years old in the comics and
when in-game comes out that will put his
age around the same this would be a good
way to tie him into Avengers in game
since it's supposed to be the
culmination of all the films in the MCU
this would certainly be a very
interesting twist on Nova but Harley
keener is supposed to be in Avengers end
game he is listed on the cast and the
president of Marvel Studios Kevin Feige
has been teasing Nova a lot lately and
there are even some plot leaks that says
Nova pops up so maybe this is a really
good way to bring Nova and Harley keiner
into Avengers in game so that's theory
number one on to number two theory
number 2 comes from Jai Mata from
Minnesota Jay has a theory that Asgard
and sack R are actually inside of the
quantum realm Jay's theory says that
both Thor and Loki go to Sekar via the
Bifrost the Bifrost is the only way
we've seen Thor get to earth and no one
aside from Jane has ever been to Asgard
The Hulk somehow went through a wormhole
and ended up in sack R but Thor and Loki
gots us a car via the Bifrost which does
work as a wormhole
Loki exits the Bifrost first followed by
Thor however when Thor gets there Loki
says that he's been there a couple of
weeks so time is kind of a
there Thor mentioned in his first movie
to Jane that where he is from science
and magic are one in the same the
quantum realm is stated to be a place
where time and space are irrelevant
Thor's also over 1500 years old he ages
the same way the Grandmaster does J
believes that Thor knows that he lives
in the quantum realm
it could be retconned as one of the nine
realms that Odin overlooked he just
called his realm Asgard Thor knows that
he lives in the quantum realm but he
hasn't had to tell anybody because it's
never been brought up it's never had to
at least in Thor's case you can travel
through space and time in the quantum
realm that's why they are both
irrelevant space and time can be
manipulated it's been in our faces from
the beginning this is a super creative
theory but there are real ways that this
makes sense and it has been talked about
for a while that the quantum realm could
be one of the nine realms that Asgard
looks over but perhaps it could be as
guard itself Jay also provided some
pictures and I have to say the city
inside of the quantum realm does sort of
look like in Asgardian City Asgard was
destroyed and thor ragnarok but maybe
when ant-man gets out of the quantum
realm it helps with the time vortexes
they can go back in time and save Asgard
so that's Theory number two on to Theory
number three number three comes from
Cameron Beryl uu with a theory on Tony
Stark's mind set after the snap Cameron
says that in the commentary of the
researchers during an infinity war they
specifically pointed out multiple times
that they wanted to show the audience
why each superhero in the movie was
motivated to stop Thanos Cameron
believes that this narrative will be
followed for in-game as well Cameron
says that for many of the characters he
believes that it is clear what they want
the snap to be undone
however the one character that I believe
may not initially have the motivation to
undo the snap is Tony Stark Pepper
hasn't showed up in any of the in-game
trailers which leads Cameron to believe
that she may be a victim to the snap
Cameron says that after Tony and nebula
are saved by rocket and Thor they return
to Earth where Tony discovers that
pepper was a victim of the snap because
of this tragic news he needs to recover
from the battle at Titan and the tension
between him and Captain America Tony
feels defeated and chooses to not travel
with the remaining Avengers to battle
Thanos instead he decides to cut his
losses by recovering from his injuries
and rebuilding what is left on earth
once again the Avengers return from
another defeat at the hands of Thanos
America tries to motivate Tony to help
them defeat Thanos but this is
unsuccessful and damages their
relationship even further after some
time has passed ant-man arrives from the
time vortex and shares where he has been
and what he has discovered about the
quantum realm with this information
Tony realizes there is hope of bringing
pepper back to life thus gaining the
motivation reuniting with the Avengers
to undo the snap and defeat Thanos this
could actually play out in Avengers
endgame this is Tony's biggest defeat
and Tony had been preparing for years
since the Battle of New York to fight
Thanos and he didn't even get close to
defeating Thanos so if Tony gets back to
earth and finds out that pepper was a
victim of the snap he might call it
quits and after just fighting Thanos
seeing how strong he is he may not think
there's a way to defeat him but if
ant-man showed up and said hey there's a
way to time travel and prevent all of
this from happening there for bringing
pepper back to life he would definitely
do it and pepper was Tony's fiancee she
was everything to him so if she dies he
may not have that motivation so I think
we could possibly see this in Avengers
endgame that does it for theory number 3
on to number 4 theory number 4 comes
from user harsh gaming with a theory
about dr. Strange's role in Avengers
endgame the theory says that we saw in
the Doctor Strange movie the ancient one
told us that no sorceress supreme can
look into the future after his or her
death which means that every outcome
which he saw an infinity war he was
alive and also the outcome in which he
tells the avengers would defeat Thanos
also in an Infinity Ward movie interview
we saw that Tom Holland tells us that he
has very easy dialogue but he says that
dr. strange had very hard dialogue
because he had a lot of stuff involving
the quantum realm which is again proof
that he is alive in a vendor's in game
his role is to help the Avengers
understand about the quantum realm and I
think that he saved Iron Man's life
because he can help Scott Lang and Bruce
Banner to make the quantum realm suit so
they can time-travel we know that dr.
strange can go into his astral form so
maybe when we saw him get dusted in
Infinity Ward that was just his body but
he went into astral form to save his
life this theory does make a lot of
sense especially because there was that
interview where they said that Benedict
Cumberbatch who plays Doctor Strange had
a lot of hard lines because of the
quantum realm so clearly he is going to
end up in the quantum realm or being a
part of it some
how and he can turn into his astral form
so maybe that's how he ends up helping
the other Avengers because he's actually
not dead but in his astral form this
would certainly be a twist that we would
not see coming which I think the Russo
brothers would really like to do so this
could possibly happen in Avengers in
game where Doctor Strange reveals that
he just went to his astral form and
didn't exactly die and from there he can
help the Avengers go inside of the
quantum realm and go get everybody else
out of the soul world so that does it
for theory number four on to the next
and final theory theory number five the
last theory comes from Walker and he
says that Thanos will kill Captain
Marvel in the beginning of Avengers
endgame this is how Walker says that
it's going to go down we see Carole
arrived at the Avengers headquarters
right after Theo snaps his fingers and
the new in-game trailer we see banter
between Carole and Thor this is a scene
that was exactly described in the
shareholders meeting
but nebula was explaining that Thanos
would be in his garden this scene we
assumed that Captain America Black Widow
nebula warmachine Thor and Rocket
Raccoon and Captain Marvel are going to
fly to space to Titan to to fight Thanos
when they get to Titan to in Thanos his
garden Thanos sees them and they lock
eyes for a few seconds as he addresses
everybody he does a head gesture towards
Thor but he notices someone new he
instantly knows who she is because of
the full gauntlet and lets out a smile
Carroll rushes him but he knocks her
down easily after the heroes fight he
picks up Carol's beaten body and starts
choking her and ends up killing her he
then gives the Avengers a chance to
leave or he will kill them this is the
defeat that makes them just give up then
ant-man gets out of the quantum realm
they travel back in time ultimately
defeat Thanos and bring everybody back
walker's reasoning behind this theory is
that in the battle scene and the suit
seen in the trailers we see all the main
heroes except for one Captain Marvel
also if they add Captain Marvel why
would they just give up and let a year
pass she wouldn't let that happen she
would do anything to restore the
universe and when they save her she will
repay them by agreeing to protect the
earth in the future by becoming a new
Avenger this could possibly happen
because Carol Danvers thinks that she is
invincible so she could very much
underestimate the power of fan o's and
the research said that this movie is
going to be all about the original six
Avengers so maybe she does get defeated
in
the beginning and killed but when the
Avengers bring everybody back if they
bring her back - and at the end they all
fight together and Kevin Feige has
recently said that Carol Danvers will
have a kryptonite in Avengers end game
and maybe Thanos knows what that is so
that's it for all this week's theories
let's do a quick recap theory number one
is that Harley keiner is an incarnation
of Nova theory number two is that Asgard
and Sekar are inside of the quantum
realm theory number three is about Tony
Stark's mindset Pepper died to the snap
and he won't fight with the rest of the
Avengers until ant-man comes back and
says that time travel is possible theory
number four is that dr. strange is not
actually dead but went into astral form
and theory number five is that Thanos
actually kills Captain Marvel in the
beginning of the movie so those are this
week's theories be sure to vote on which
one you thought was your favorite and
again if you would like to enter your
own theory for a chance to end up on
Theory Thursdays you can find the email
and the instructions in the description
down below and of course don't forget to
subscribe so you can stay up to date on
Theory Thursdays and stay up to date on
everything relating to Avengers endgame
and Marvel as always thank you all so
much for watching
woof woof
[Music]
you